I was closeted for most of my life my
adult life I wanted to be an actor which
alone just that alone was some people
thought a crazy at aspiration to have
because I am asian and Asians first of
all are don't have many opportunities to
get cast plus the fact that there were
stereotypes that we were saddled with
either the cold heartless killer the
inscrutable a person that's got
something always going on in the back of
his mind leading to suspicion that where
we could be spies or the survial the
quiet obsequious or the buffoon all very
unattractive stereotypes so why I would
go into acting but something that well
I'm the black sheep of the family my
parents thought it was absolutely crazy
but they knew how passionate I was and
to get cast with first this ethnic
barrier a hurdle for me to cross I
didn't want to add another one of being
gay gay people were not cast or if they
were exposed as gay their careers faded
I remember when I was a teenager there
was a very good looking handsome actor
named Tab Hunter who was a contract
actor with Warner Brothers and almost
every other movie coming from Warner
Brothers starred Tab Hunter he was the
heartthrob of America until confidential
exposed him as being gay and eventually
he disappeared that was an object lesson
for me and so I was closeted and my
career was making
progress and so I did everything to
protect my career which meant having my
guard up all the time being careful
about the pronouns I used a denying some
a good portion of who I was it was a
very uncomfortable a way to live except
that when you're doing it it becomes a
part of your normal existence I live
that uncomfortable existence as what I
thought was going to be my life you know
I used to go to gay bars in Los Angeles
back then and it was a wonderful place
where that guard can come down I could
make friends as Who I am and to really
relax and enjoy friendship camaraderie
and a wonderful evening or an afternoon
that but one of the older people told me
that periodically the police would raid
gay bars and they would March the
clients out put them on a paddy wagon
drive him to the police station
fingerprint them photographed them and
their names would be put on a list it
was terrifying their lives could be
destroyed they could lose their jobs
perhaps their families it was a horrible
thing and what were they doing a
criminal activity according to the law
at that time being gay was criminalized
we were marched out put into paddy
wagons and registered and I thought
that's no different different than what
happened to me when I was child because
of this face because we looked like the
people that bomb Pearl Harbor we were
put into prison camps got it over by
soldiers with machine guns point
Don Mathers from century towers it was
the same thing and I thought that was a
horrible that was wrong unjust and yet
that was the way we had to live those
few isolated moments when we could be
ourselves and then Stonewall happened
when the people there resisted they
decided they had had enough they're not
going to take it anymore and that was
the galvanizing event and society began
to change and by the 21st century things
were really starting to change
Massachusetts they as a state Supreme
Court of Massachusetts ruled that
marriage equality was constitutional so
that was the first state two years later
on the other coast in California the
people's representatives this time
through the legislative route both
houses of the California Legislature the
assembly and the Senate passed the
marriage equality bill all that that
bill needed was a signature of the
governor to become the law of the state
it would have been two states bookending
America with marriage equality the
governor at that time happened to be a
movie star Arnold Schwarzenegger when he
campaigned for that office he told the
public I'm from Hollywood I've worked
with gays and lesbians so my best
friends are gays and lesbians and
persuaded by that a couple of my gay
friends did vote for him yet when that
bill landed on his desk he acted as the
representative of his base the right
wing of the Republican Party and he
vetoed it I was raging but I had trained
my body muscularly to hold in that rage
and that night Brad and I were watching
the late
nite news and i saw all these young
people pouring out on the Santa Monica
Boulevard venting their rage on Arnold
Schwarzenegger and we felt the same way
and it got us to thinking and talking
and Brad and I discussed it I was 68
years old by that time and I thought
well I want my life to have some meaning
I want the time that I have left to do
something about that aspect of who we
are and so I spoke to the press for the
first time as a gay man and I blasted
Arnold Schwarzenegger is Vito and what I
thought of my career that I thought it
was going to go on the downhill side the
opposite happened it just blossomed and
I've been working more since coming out
then I'd been when I was closeted
you